It's not an easy job teaching children right
from wrong, or the tough truths of the word,
let alone keep them entertained.
Sometimes, a TV shows attempts to grab attention
(or headlines) can lead to some episodes that
were destined to be banned and destroyed.
By all accounts, there is no reason these
stories should have ever been made let alone
make it to the air.
Here are Screenrant's 10 Banned Kid Show Episodes
You Won't Believe.
TaleSpin – “Flying Dupes”
The Disney series that took the animal stars
of The Jungle Book into the world of commercial
air transport couldn't be too serious with
Baloo as it's star.
But one episode banned by Disney had too many
problems to count.
The final episode of the series had Baloo
deliver a bomb to a foreign leader's home,
in hopes that the resulting war would mean
high profits for bomb makers.
Baloo didn't know he was attempting an assassination,
but the terrorist themes, and transport of
a bomb on an airplane alone make it hard to
believe it actually made it to air.
Unsurprisingly, Disney permanently banned
the episode shortly after.
Peppa Pig – “Mister Skinnylegs”
When you're a kid, there are too many things
to be afraid of to even count.
The British animated show Peppa Pig set out
to tackle that problem by explaining that
spiders might seem scary, but can't really
hurt you.
The message was a good one in Britain, but
in Australia, where spiders actually CAN kill
you, broadcasters saw a horrible problem brewing.
Rather than encouraging kids to get close
to venomous spiders, the episode of the series
was deemed unsuitable for public safety, and
banned.
Tiny Toon Adventures – “One Beer”
Children's TV shows and cartoons make an habit
of setting a good example for younger viewers,
with episodes meant to spread awareness about
drugs, alcohol or abuse all but expected.
But just like every other issue, Tiny Toons
took that idea beyond the extreme.
The youngsters Buster, Plucky and Hampton
down a beer knowing they're going to teach
young viewers a lesson, but the bender that
followed gets out of hand fast.
After stealing a cop car and plunging to their
deaths, the studio decided the story went
too far, even if it was all a joke.
Although the episode still airs in Canada,
it's banned on American airwaves.
Sailor Moon – Young Love
The story of young girls turned into superheroes
was an absolute phenomenon when it hit American
shores, but the addition of English voices
wasn't the only change made when bringing
the show from Japan.
Fans may never have realized that in its original
form, Sailors Neptune and Uranus aren't just
friends, but lovers.
Rather than deal with a lesbian relationship
in a kids cartoon, other countries came up
with some strange solutions.
For starters, editing out or refusing to air
episodes that hinged on their romance.
In America, the pair were written as "cousins,"
which made their flirting even more unsettling.
But in Russia and France, Sailor Uranus' civilian
form was claimed to be a man, with Neptune
pretending to be his girlfriend to keep their
superhero identities a secret - even going
so far as hiring a male voice actor for the
part.
Gargoyles – “Deadly Force”
This cult hit from Disney TV offers one more
example of the times when trying to teach
kids a lesson ends up shocking more than it
helps.
Playing off the idea that violent movies and
video games glorify violence and gunslingers,
the not-too-bright gargoyle Broadway learns
that guns aren't toys - in as shocking and
traumatic a way as possible.
While playing with the service weapons of
the group's human ally Elisa, Broadway ends
up shooting her by accident.
Understandably, parents and protest groups
complained about their kids watching a beloved
cartoon hero shoot a woman and put her in
intensive care.
The episode was banned for re-airings, but
has more recently returned to the rotation.
Arthur – “Room to Ride”
Sometimes, a plot line or celebrity cameo
can make sense at the time, but events in
the real world conspire to make it an awkward
problem for networks to solve.
When the children's cartoon Arthur decided
to tackle the issue of cycling on city streets,
Binky turns to a reliable expert for inspiration:
Tour de France champion Lance Armstrong.
Just a few years later, Armstrong would admit
to taking banned substances, and be stripped
of his seven championships.
It was probably in the show's best interest
to make sure the episode would also reflect
the ruling, stripping him of a cameo to top
everything off.
Mister Rogers’ Neighborhood – “Conflict”
Few children's TV hosts are as respected as
Mr. Rogers, and an entire week's worth of
episodes might have gotten banned for trying
to teach kids *too much*.
The five episodes focused squarely on giving
kids a crash course in the Cold War - and
the paranoia and fear that helped it spin
out of control by the time they aired in 1983.
A strange package delivered to Corny the Beaver
is all Good King Friday needed to suspect
him of amassing a nuclear arsenal, letting
fear escalate the situation.
The analogy worked, but the subject matter
was just too frightening for kids to handle,
and the storyline was never aired again.
Dexter’s Laboratory – “Dial M For Monkey”
Aside from the central plot of each episode
of Dexter's Laboratory, the 'Dial M For Monkey'
segment gave comic book superheroes a top-notch
send up.
Parodying heroes from Nick Fury to the Fantastic
Four, one episode starring "the Silver Spooner"
caused seem controversy.
It wasn't the presence of a drunk Hulk, or
even a ripoff of Marvel's Galactus - but the
fact that Silver Spooner was one long joke
based on gay stereotypes.
The writers may have thought they were being
clever, but the episode was never aired with
other reruns of the series.
Sesame Street – Wicked Witch of The West
That's right, even sesame street wasn't safe
from the terror of the Wizard of Oz antagonist,
with the Witch - played by Margaret Hamilton
- appearing after dropping her broom around
Mr. Hooper's store.
Naturally, Oscar the Grouch was immediately
fond of the Witch, but kids at home apparently
weren't.
When parents complained en mass that the Villains
appearance had upset their kids or reduced
then to tears, the network acted fast.
The apparent terror was nowhere to be found
in test audiences, but figured they would
play it safe anyway.
The episode hasn't aired since.
Pokemon – “Electric Soldier Porygon”
The fun of this infamous episode all started
when Ash was forced to travel inside the depths
of one of his own Poke balls.
When Pikachu used lightning to detonate incoming
missiles, he saved the day.
But for the kids watching the show, things
didn't go so smoothly.
The flashing red and blue explosion sent almost
700 Japanese children into bouts of dizziness,
headaches, blurred vision, or in some cases,
even seizures.
"Pokemon Shock" made headlines around the
world, but didn't just get the episode banned
- the entire show went on a four month break.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss out on any of your favorite TV
shows that got episodes pulled from the air?
Be sure to share them in the comments, and
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.